can you right now tell us about sorry
the uh like this transmission of your
Quran how did it come into existence you
can okay so so what what you're doing
now right now was that what was that's
exactly what we're doing we're finding
out before okay because you said who
wrote the Bible right you're saying the
Bible wasn't written by it is he with
you or is he with me
I don't know do you know him
you don't know him okay so we can ask
him what we're just speaking about no no
okay
no no
don't be on camera I just want to ask
you one thing and let it let me click
don't run don't run no no no don't be on
camera what was we just talking about
so I mentioned I'm just laying this I
haven't even discussed anything yet
we're just showing people what we were
just talking about off camera so I
mentioned the I am statements in John
and I mentioned the Gospel of John and
you said with regards to John that we
have a chain of transmission of John and
uh we can actually uh the early church
fathers they demonstrated that John
wrote John because this is my question
to you how did John John then you said
some one of the early church fathers
said that it was John that wrote it and
asked you who you know the name but it
was irenaeus of uh I think it was 180
irony
is
important to Islam yeah but it's not
important to Christianity exactly
because we know where it comes from and
it's not like oh did he say that or did
you
see you see
we're going to talk over each other you
just woke up you just caught me I just I
haven't made my claim yet
I'll give you time yeah
one of these guys I'm reasonable
yeah it seems like you are so I like
speaking to you yeah so I just want it
to be time because I hated if I spoke
over you
that's fine
that's fine JC can we get a camera with
somebody
do you want two or three minutes
whatever whatever
all right thank you so so he's gonna
keep trying yeah yeah so your Muslim
brother
so so once he starts the time can you
start the time for him please
yeah so for me this is I don't do Time
stuff but I'm doing it for your sake no
problem
um we can do three minutes it's not it's
not about that at all it's just I'm not
used to I'm not used to these uh time
discussions but it's no problem so this
is what I mentioned to you earlier was
about the Gospel of John in John we have
the Great I Am statements before Abraham
was I am I am the father one you are
going from one place to another what is
the topic let me know
okay let's let's say here okay here
his name
so so he was disgusted with one of my
other brothers he's not here now
um and then he was asking about the
categorization between authentic
narrations
okay so I basically I didn't know the
the the the the full details of what
they were saying but I listened to a
little bit and I said okay I'm just
going to clarify one thing about
authentic narrations so he was satisfied
with the answer and that was it that was
the end of it I then asked him can I ask
you now about your mode of transmission
in Christianity and you I think I'm sure
I remember you being there at that time
so I then asked for example John before
Abraham was I am we find a statement in
John before Abraham was Ayan
um how do we know that John John and I
was speaking to the gentleman in the the
blue polo shirt and I was speaking to
him both of these two and then I said do
we know that John wrote John and then
you jumped in and said yes we know that
John wrote John and I said how do we
know that John wrote John you said he's
the Beloved disciple I asked how do you
know that he's the Beloved disciple
firstly and secondly with the end of
John John 21 who who's speaking there
where it says and just for the record if
you don't mind
yeah but we're gonna have a specific
topic because I'm gonna ask you
questions about Quran is that okay so
right now we discussed the Quran
initially they discussed it before I
even came I wasn't there okay but I'm
asking my question you're gonna ask me
questions but I'm gonna ask you a
question yeah if you answer my question
of course yeah so if we're discussing
one thing in detail okay it's not one
thing in detail it's not works like this
you made the claim that John wrote John
I made the claim that we have a you I
gave you the change you don't answer you
don't answer John wrote John because the
Quran XYZ that's not how you that's not
if you're talking about this as a
specific subject you made the claim to
me I was discussing with these guys
freely you made the claim to me yes we
know John wrote John I was like okay how
did you know I don't know John now
you're saying and I gave you the answer
right what did you say I did not say
that we had the early church fathers
there yeah and at this question before
and they did answer it at that time with
the and I'm questioning that that's the
point you don't you don't answer John
John by saying that's the second
question
the thing is this the thing is I I came
in here they asked me a question I
clarified my answer I spoke at lymph I
answered
both of these two guys okay
um so are you afraid of answering
questions about Islam are you afraid
you're afraid I'm not I am
do you agree that this is a different
subject
you can do you agree do you agree it's a
different subject no
I'd ask you I said to you how I said to
you
because you're saying I want to ask you
a question but you cannot ask me
questions
no it's not you cannot ask me a question
and if I ask you a question today no no
no you can't ask me a question that's a
whole different subject no no okay
I don't have reliability what I'm saying
what I'm saying what's the reliability
yeah yeah you could you could question
that you should answer you can question
that and we can discuss that that's our
problem but in a discussion on genre and
John okay when for example these
academic non-muslim Scholars when they
discuss it do they bring in the Quran do
they say well
no no no no no no no no no no no because
because what I what I don't want to do
is enter a discussion and you start
machine gunning throwing everything the
question was simple no no listen to me
listen to me
listen I spoke to three of you at the
same time
you were talking to these guys they
didn't have the address he said can you
come over here
okay so I'm speaking to him I was
speaking to the other the older one the
older one over there okay Andrew as well
at the same time yes yes no no no no no
no yes yes
listen listen listen you butted into the
conversation then if you want to put it
down
listen listen listen listen if you don't
want to answer just say yes written
ridiculous
I don't know which one is
for example
but if you ask me the same question I'm
gonna run away and I have a right to do
that because I'm gonna say well you're
not answering my question sir
your Quran you cannot you say this book
is not authenticated your Quran has no
original manuscript okay you don't have
it all right
okay first you seem like a reasonable
guy but clearly use life clearly he was
being deceitful you said you seemed I I
said to you I'm trying to be reasonable
we can do two minutes if you want to do
two minutes every time I've spoke now
you've jumped and stopped because you're
scared of this irony question which
we'll have to get back to but because
now you've done exactly what I said you
shouldn't do in a discussion like this
if we're discussing one thing you bring
up a whole different subject and says
what about this go go point for point
I'm not just gonna accept if I don't
accept bukhari said X on that therefore
uh I have to blindly follow buhari has
the show is working so when you said
irenaeus says
um x y o z i don't just accept irony
it's like I have the right to question
it let alone you telling me irony said
it therefore you can't question of
course I have the right to ask you now
because you've mentioned you've done
this whole diversion tactic and asking
yes you have because you've done this
whole diversion tactic of asking about
quranic manuscripts again opposing your
beliefs opposing your belief upon us our
religion is not based our transmission
of the Quran is not based upon
manuscripts that's the first mistake
you've made now your religion is based
upon manuscripts from unknown authors
that you have to stop timing this no no
no no if you're not being patients
fine
um so all you've done is just divert now
you I want to talk about one subject
so in terms of the first one Abu Bakr
had a Quran That Was Then passed down to
Aisha no doubt uh Ali had a compilation
uh many of the sahaba had compilation if
you're asking of the first one it's very
hard to tell because they're all in the
prophet's lifetime okay now in terms of
manuscript the prophet's lifetime
companions wrote down their mind I'm
talking about compilation in terms of in
Terms every uh
they all had their own compilation of
the Quran it was under Usman that it was
unified under one okay now this has
nothing to do with irenaeus saying that
John wrote John the only reason you've
done that is because you didn't know
what you were talking about okay
again
are you gonna are we gonna do like Bible
and foreign
and then when I mention about my
criticism for about irony is and then I
show you this is the Bible right now
you're not going to talk about nothing
about the Bible you're only going to
diver which is not really speaking about
so I guarantee all these cameras are
watching you're not going to say nothing
about irenaeus and my rebuttal to It Go
on okay
let me say something
you've had your say right so I can say
now I'm waiting for you to talk about
rnas
I don't have to talk about what you want
me to talk about I know you want me to
want me to something that was the whole
discussion that was the whole discussion
I'm gonna say that was the whole
discussion
do what you say then then you know what
um just one thing you know what happens
if you do that if you open up that kind
of worms I'll move to a topic topic then
that allows you don't even listening to
me you have a good time
just now you allowed me to speak okay
prior to that you was calling me You You
You elevated the tone of this discussion
not me yeah I'm bringing it down so try
and bring it down please okay the
cameras are watching now so they're
watching for you so before that we was
talking about iron is no problem as soon
as the cameras came you started to jump
it became irate and then you wanted to
jump
back and forth so what I want to say if
you if you do this thing if you do this
thing where every time I question
something you say well what about this
what about that what about that then
then when you're asking me now imagine
if I was to do the same thing
so when what you just did now I'll ask
you a specific question we had a
discussion earlier with the other guys
and then I'll answer the specific
question and then you said well what
about this now imagine now when you ask
me what about this I asked you about
something else now how many topics are
we going to go through without even
understanding one now I guarantee you
that when you speak you're not going to
address irony is you're just gonna jump
to the Quran so go you speak now yes
thank you okay
I have no problem talking about the
Bible and I did that before and I tried
to explain to you Christianity did not
start when the Bible was written
[Music]
his childhood he started way before the
Bible was
okay so our our faith and our religion
is not based on what narration who and
this and that our base our faith is
totally even there was no Bible written
because of what Jesus did and if you
believe that you'll be saved that's our
belief so this whole thing about
narration and who wrote this and what
does it say this is because of your
perspective because your Quran has
nobody who wrote down the Quran you have
you don't have Quran which was the first
compilation why you don't have it you
don't and not just you have asked a lot
of Muslims here nobody knows why you
don't have it why do you not have the
full utmani Quran nobody knows where the
where the copies of those qurans were
sent to the capitals of Islamic World
which was ruling those areas there was
no Jew or Christian who took it from
them they had it now they don't have it
and those were not written on paper like
Bible was in the beginning it was
written on parchment which lasts for
centuries so those things would not have
been disappeared unless your people did
it so you don't have your Quran you
don't know who wrote it okay you have
people you say well there was the name
of the who wrote
how do we know wrote all their eyes in
there there are so many discrepancies
in your own Islamic narrative there are
oh I used to say this now I forgot about
this one there are so many examples
I will be done and then you will know
and then don't let you sleep now in in
the Bible like you say oh yeah how do we
know I said listen
Christianity was your hadees Hadith are
the sayings of the prophets
look we are not counting the time he
said don't count the time hadees were
written 200 years after Muhammad these
These are hadees the red letters in here
are the Christian hadees which means
what Jesus said the sayings of Jesus are
the hadees of Jesus these are in here
these were written within 90 years of
Jesus
and now I have like two not hardly two
minutes
listen how many minutes did you have was
it more than two minutes of course
if it was okay just wrap it off and you
kept interrupting him
and the topic was
okay
[Music]
the beginning of Christianity from the
people who were there okay so so if you
come across and say well we don't know
this and that this is like something
that's it that's fine that's fine
no no no no no you're running away from
the Quran and you're hadees I'll give
you two minutes
you're gonna get two minutes are we
doing two minutes just wrap it up just
wrap it up please is there anything else
you want to ask
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna have my last
say and we'll give it 30 seconds okay
Bible was written by the people who were
there the eyewitnesses it has been
attested by the eyewitnesses you don't
need a chain of religion when you have
energy all right
that's fine
Liberties I have Liberty you don't have
Liberty that's fine you're it's in Islam
you don't have Liberty I have Liberty
okay now you're attacking okay
you're saying you're Taking Liberties
don't take liberties with the time
just let me speak okay so no it's now
that you did not address anything at all
to do with irenaeus now we discussed
these guys before we had this discussion
you made the claim that John wrote John
I was speaking to speak to someone else
and you buy it in and said yes John
wrote John
now you made the claim not me I didn't
claim that when I asked you to
demonstrate it you said yes we can the
church fathers I asked which church
Farmers you didn't know the name I said
what irony is 180
um you said you said yes that's the one
so it was you that made the claim so why
are you saying now this claim is not
important okay you open the Bible and
you said that these are our narrations
these uh Red Letters you open a Red
Letter Bible and you said these are the
narrations of fun in the in the gospel
these are Hadith the manuscripts that
you have I told you already our religion
is not based our sources are not based
upon manuscripts okay you have change of
transmission and it's mad it's not and
consensus at every time when you mention
these and this is this is the irony
this is the irony they have a problem
with bukhari most of their manuscripts
that they use to to to revive their text
come after the after bukhari not after
Jesus after bukhari we often hear from
you we often hear from Christians now
that the most uh the most widely uh
attested to uh manuscript uh uh document
in history from manuscript tradition is
the Bible we have thousands and
thousands of thousands of manuscripts
okay he's burning now now what we say is
that most of these manuscripts 95 or 93
have done the maps itself they come off
the buhari but yet they attack buhari
like they did earlier they have a
problem with buhari who died a few
centuries after after uh
but yet their manuscripts come after the
bukhari so we go back to the original
question how do you transmit anything
from Jesus all the Great I Am statements
where you claim that Jesus is God before
Abraham was I am I am the father of one
uh I am the way the truth that I've
found in John I showed him at the end of
John if you don't mind the end of John
it mentions
the end of John again just through the
record he never adjusted it
this is the disciple which testifies of
these things and wrote these things and
we know that his testimony is true my
question to him earlier which he wasn't
which he clearly said he don't know and
I want him to say he doesn't know on
camera who is the we
and who is this we know that his
testimony is true this we here they're
speaking first person plural they're
giving us the transmission now if this
is the the gospel with the highest
christology the highest view of Jesus
yeah how can they now not know who that
we is when we're getting the that view
of Jesus that shows that he's God we're
getting this through these unknown
people so he didn't so he didn't he
didn't address anything to do with how
do we know that what irony says is true
that John wrote John he never addressed
anything like that at all I'll give him
another opportunity to address it and
I'll also ask him who is the we just for
the record he mentioned earlier that he
doesn't know who the we is I just want
to see if he's consistent and he's good
good enough to say that on camera he
doesn't know who who wrote this part
here of we as in the one who's
transmitting to us the second thing
because you mentioned the Quran we have
to deal with it the only thing he can do
rather than address the answer he has to
say
okay we have chains of transmission with
biographies of scholar us and
transmitted from the companions in fact
I've set in front of Scholars for
example 27 people in the chain time he
shows his he shows his on our wrap up
now he shows his transmission and it's
not the shuffle with many scholars they
have chains of transmission where they
can show the name of the people in the
internet but we don't even need that
that's for ad narrations we have ishma
consensus in the time of Usman why
didn't they rebel against us man those
who Usman was killed why did they knock
video for change in the Quran they
killed him for something else why didn't
the easiest thing they could have said
he corrupted the Quran nobody had that
connection
what is that 30 seconds over a minute no
problem okay thank you no problem it's
all right okay I didn't address now
let's address the we he said who was the
we in the
yeah I'm listening now okay thank you
all right you asked
who's the win and how do we know irony
is my two main questions who's the Wii
and how do we know the irenaeus when he
said John wrote John how do we know he's
correct where's he's working please okay
so the we are the Christians
we are the Christians about him is Jesus
that his testimony is true wow that's
what the answer is now uh Irene is I I
just told you that in Christianity
our faith is not because our Bible is
transmitted by our Witnesses and the
people who interviewed their private in
the first generation
we don't need a long chain of narration
because we're not writing those things
to 300 years after the fact
okay so we don't need what you have your
your Quran and your hadees are dependent
on religion because you don't have any
why Witnesses do any of those statements
so there are a lot of problems with
those narrations that you're talking
about it's not a lot of people don't
even believe in all the Hadith I come
here weekly I talk to Muslims when I
show them are these they said oh I don't
believe in that Hadith
no I don't have to believe it oh it's
not the word of Allah I only believe in
Quran how many times they dance around
it's unbelievable it's already on camera
you if you guys are like picking up the
things you you don't have anything once
you look at your boat
your the questions that Muslims ask are
because of the problems they have with
their texts they think that those same
problems can be applied to the Bible it
cannot because the Bible does not work
like this with the Quran does because it
was been written 300 years after the
fact it was written by the people or the
people who were
interviewing the I Witnesses that's my
answer what's your other question if I'm
forgetting something I want to cover it
so the two ones are it should have been
three but two ones are RC uh here's the
we I ask you that okay we're gonna check
that and Irene is when he says John
wrote John where did he get out from
okay he's the Church Father this is from
the people that were there so okay so
you're saying John had disciples uh
polycarby said is one of the disciples
there are others that are there so
they're the ones who are there to know
if John is not correct or if this is
something not written by him they can
correct that Allah
did that you have narration oh someone
that called this and his father Jack and
that's father uncle said this that
Muhammad said this
we don't have that
and then some of them said no no that's
no no that's not I'm not a reliable and
even if it's if it doesn't uh work with
the Quran then we don't accept it even
if it has a China I asked this question
10 times if it has a chain of donation
is well maybe not because if it has its
right chain of duration but it doesn't
work with the Quran so you know theology
then we don't consider it that's how
your religion works and you think that
that's how the Christian Christianity
doesn't work like that we don't have
these issues you guys have this issues
that's my answer okay so notice again he
said something which is uh four fingers
I wanna four points if you don't monitor
for your Bible again yeah he said
on camera and I'm shocked at this one
I'm very shocked at this he said on
camera that
this is the disciple which testifies
these things and wrote these things and
we know that his testimony is true he
said the hidden here is Jesus
you're actually on camera he said yes
yeah he said he said understanding is
different than ours so who's the listen
this is the disciple
is that Jesus if he's saying that's
Jesus this is the first ever okay other
Christians so now the testimony of Jesus
is correct so that's all we're saying so
now this disciple here who is it
who is the disciple John okay which
testifies of these things and wrote
these things you said that was Jesus no
he said the testify that his testimony
Jesus
this is the this is the disciple okay my
friend no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no this is not what I'm
speaking now I'm speaking now let's find
this on camera
anymore because he's keep giving his
interpretation of that and saying yeah
if there's any Muslim cameras
you must be you know you're wrong you
know you're wrong I'm not no Christian
no Christian
um Exodus exegesis as far as I'm aware
would ever say that this the disciple
who wrote these things and testify these
things is Jesus I'm speaking yes no no
he just said it he said it he said it
okay fine fine the thing with the thing
that I mentioned earlier before the
camera how do we know that John is the
Beloved disciple he said someone else
said it so we believe it the second
thing is who's the weak
he said earlier off camera we don't know
who the Wii is yeah no no no no I'm
speaking
so do you agree now I know and he said
earlier that we that the we is unknown
we don't know who the we is no I said
there are the Christians
the Christians the Christians yes is
that your answer
okay which questions
that he's addressing in the book did
Christians lie in the name of Jesus did
some did some Christians by the name of
Jesus I don't know we're not going
through that wow why because because
goes back to the same topic about
forgery how do we understand forgery for
him being Christian is enough if a
Christian says to you jump off a cliff
you're going to land on a bouncy castle
that's enough
um if a Christian says he's not changing
the topics
no no because the we here you don't know
who it is
when these people when they attack Islam
they they kind of attack Islam except my
food into the same criticism that they
criticize the Muslims with but yeah let
me finish no you didn't address attack
on Islam because you can't address and
finish you cannot address the attack
that I did on Islam right now I said to
you
because you don't have everything I was
patient
for him
he said he said he said let's hold it
down he said that Muslims do my uncle
this Uncle he just said Christians he
said this is the highest christology
this gospel but he said well Christians
said it so we accept it but then when he
said to the Muslims oh they take from
their uncles no we don't take it from
our uncles and so and so we take from
the names of the people he mentioned
eyewitnesses
one of the conditions one of the
conditions over authentic Hadith is that
is
connected chain a Hadith that has uh is
is disconnected like the Muslim for
example is a category of weak narration
where the sahabi with a where the
eyewitness is missing that's the
category of weak narration
I'm speaking and I never caught you so
then he says we have eyewitnesses okay
for us on our first generation has to
come by us the hobby eyewitness okay
same with the Quran the Quran uh
resention that we have comes via Abu
Bakr comes from sorry from Ali from
Usman from many of the it's a joke yeah
the second thing now is that he said we
have eyewitnesses and I'm so glad he
said it
was Luke an eyewitness no no was Mark an
eyewitness news
[Music]
I said eyewitnesses and we have people
who wait who interviewed eyewitness okay
I'll give you the right account so so he
said that so now let's look at this
example he caught me now let's look for
example
shooting me all over the place I'm gonna
have to come in and correct why did I
not cut you even though you left I
didn't misclude you I don't do it I'm
not a Muslim questions
to get away from the plane now what he
said he says that we have eyewitnesses
okay I asked who these eyewitnesses he
said Christians
another lie I said in here he's
addressing Christians I didn't say yes
who had no input in that in that text or
in that verse they're just passive
audience
oh you
oh yeah
so for example please stop miscoding
lies okay